ce soir on assiste quand même au premier
échec politique d' emmanuel macron le
rappelle qu'au mois de juillet on nous
annonce est un groupe la république en
marche à 90 et puis tout au long de
l'été ça a les ambitions se sont
réduites et finalement ce soir on n'a
pas le nombre exact mais
vraisemblablement on sera au point de
départ c'est à dire moins de trente
sénateurs la république en marche entre
20 et rhône et le président du groupe
il faut le dire clairement c'est un
échec pour emmanuel macron alors il faut
dire qu'il a tout fait tour parce
qu'entre la suppression de la réserve
parlementaire de la fin des contrats
aidés ils pouvaient pas faire davantage
pour limiter le succès des candidats
estampillés par le premier